the first photographer to capture the
blonde was there right and are you
normally read or um so when I first came
out I was trimmed I had and just lost my
husband so I am shamed might have had a
GI Jane moment so definitely coming out
and growing out my hair during the
beginning phase of my womanhood was
definitely a challenge since um that
does you know define a lot of your
family femininity that's right
what what age were you would you camera
here is it three years ago only three
years ago how old are you know I am 30
years old 30 and were you did you know
that you had this inclination that as a
younger man I think that like when your
answer that I think when you're younger
you kind of don't really think future
terms of gender you just think you just
feel and do you don't you know like guys
or girls you're just like ill boys it'll
girls so I've definitely always been
calm down and you've had surgeries I
have only had a little touch on my lips
in Chicago okay so tell me about your
childhood you grew up where I grew up in
Dallas Texas Alex in New York and Los
Angeles and I had a great childhood lots
of love support so much love that you
know I at the end of the day I truly
think that there's more good in the
world than bad sounds great and so you
had both your parents yes
divorced but still um still very equal
you know weekends in New York with my
dad and we with my mom and now are there
signs of this coming when you were like
a teenager
a little bit I think it's one of those
things where you try to express
something as someone but closed mouth
don't get fed
I was trying to show my family living
etc but I never said it you know I never
fully said it until my divorce from my
husband so that definitely made the
woman come out for sure so and how did
your family react to that they've um
they've kind of taken it as you know um
they don't really my family worries more
about me being a good person and taking
care of myself physically emotionally
psychologically I think what you choose
to do you know in the world or bedroom
you know that kind of your my parents I
can only speak for myself they just want
to see me happy and you know mom and I
definitely see through everything so I
try to you know come on
you know happy face if you will but they
definitely want me to be a happy you
know healthy person was great to hear so
you you had relationships with men
before yes I am a hetero trans woman I'm
not and I don't like I said judge to
each their own
um I've never had a I guess a trans be
an experience but that's alert I word I
learned from the community it's trans
and the word lesbian kind of morphed
which is trans bein so I have a lot of
close girlfriends by the number I'm
gonna pissed a girl but okay what kind
could be you in high school
pardon what kind of kid were you in high
school I was um I was gothic preppy
beater all those into one big mm-hmm
and then you moved from Dallas to Dallas
to Orange County when I was 20 then
that's when I met my ex ex-husband and
we came to Dallas then I left him and
moved back to California got it okay and
her so you're living
we are you living on Skid Row now that's
where I met you yeah um I literally did
not even know that was Skid Row I was in
your Melrose my friend invited me not
this guy online in a nutshell he begged
me to LA I said he heard me to Hollywood
okay
you never turned down Hollywood so I
said sure and his credit card wasn't
working quote unquote and I've been here
for 24 hours and I just revealed my
golden locks so super huge thing tonight
um undisclosed location you don't know
yet thank out okay you'll figure it out
absolutely always so you're not homeless
you you've always had a place to stay
oh yeah I've always had a roof over your
head I always have had a roof over my
head um they've probably been I would
say four or five days where you kind of
got to keep it going and those days I
don't like to put that in my hand
because when you put your feet in your
hug it doesn't the universe doesn't um
for me for you know I could only speak
for myself and I have to excuse my nails
that are not done during this apocalypse
going on I just found them they are you
had no time to prepare for now time I
plucked you off the street yeah so um
definitely um it's throwing me back on
how to plumb them out what were we just
what I was thinking or are we out there
I can't recall but so you're down here
to find Skid Row
there's lots of drugs down here or drugs
are part of your life um I um there's
something that how do I answer that
question before
but surprisingly that's not why I'm here
today
okay I buy it what do you do for money
um I what do I do for money I was I've
heard everything so you're nothing
you're gonna tell me as a friend I'm
nothing in a nutshell I grew up with
money
Maron and it's money made my own money I
would say him an escort but I'm a
terrible at being a seductive etcetera
once you get to know me that's I'm but
you have a client you have clientele
that appreciate your I don't I just um I
grew into my looks and I just guys
helped me out I asked you know I can't
put a price to my sexuality or to my
time I just built relationships and I'm
like hey you know so what's going on so
you know so to answer that I think we're
all in this world pimps and hoes if you
also just some extent and you get
treated nicely in general life generally
generally uh I've always have felt
personally and I'm just it's probably
because of the date cetera I've always
felt kind of like a trophy and in this
world you know you have to one of my
Dean's at GD Conservatory in Dallas
Texas
um said Deming once you realize your
place and the pen or something it was
really I can't quote it exactly so
that's you know realizing that I'm
living in a world and I've have a
certain look skills assets I'm just
going with that as if that makes sense
yeah weird artistically sorry sure
okay what plans do you have real life
you're still young where do you see
yourself I want to be um I want to be a
respected artist I want to be an
accomplished artist I want to be a
strong businesswoman
I want to I still believe in love
regardless of my abusive marriage that
would you know the whole Orange County
mom I saw this one lady you know in her
leggings jogging with her she's
literally running with a stroller just
pushing and I was like and she had this
like blond ponytail I was like wow
that's I mean it's a beautiful day she's
running and her you know that's you know
so I would like to have my own family be
healthy and happy yeah my um something
happened when you say an artist what
what is your um I think that's them as
artists we I'm not necessarily a painter
photographer et cetera I've doubled but
I too have somewhat of a formal
education and acting drama Fine Arts so
you have any issues like with with
anxiety or depression or anger or stuff
like that um I do part of me I do have
anxiety I've seen the same therapist for
15 or psychiatrist dr. uptown family
medicine did I haven't just X throwing
in the side note an excellent said have
you only seen that psychiatrist I said
no I've had other therapists so don't
but yeah the only thing I do suffer from
is extreme social anxiety its ability to
um that's kind of what kept me from
making friends that you all not so much
my feminism not so much the way I act
whatever I'm I kind of have a tendency
to seclude myself and I stick out so
much that I can't really be with the
group which I'd like to you know what is
your fear oh pardon me what is your fear
probably irrational but what is your
yeah probably
probably um someone hurting me which has
the only person that's ever physically
hurt me husband the guy I just married
which breaks my heart but made me
stronger too but that's part of being a
woman as heart break down my voice
teacher always said deme men see [ __ ]
and women don't and to take everything
life I'm a huge crier which sucks with
my allergies and makeup etc to take
everything all the feeling that life
throws at you and just is the hardest
thing about being wrong all right do me
well thank you so much for sharing your
story and very nice me too you know
thank you very much
you